okay who's calling today from the 602
area code caller from 602 yes great
Julie if you can speak up a little bit
that would be very much appreciated
okay I'm using I'm using earphones I
didn't have to be on speaker does that
work yes what's your question today okay
I was wondering about
I'm very left-wing obviously being in
Europe but I was wondering about voter
ID laws that the less we perspective to
hear because to me in the Netherlands
that's like that's a normal thing
everyone has an ID everyone's required
to have an ID from the time they're a
teenager yeah I mean so everything's
completely different in another one so I
understand what you're saying and I
understand that there is a sort of very
simplistic case to be made that like
listen the IDS are free and just
everybody needs an ID and that's it but
unfortunately in in reality in the
United States it's been extremely
politicized in the United States not
everyone automatically gets these IDs
when they're teenagers and thus as
adults you are required to present other
documents which themselves do have costs
associated with them and so I get what
you're saying in the Netherlands the
Netherlands is functioning far better on
this issue than the United States but
it's not equivalent for that reason I
was just kind of curious if she could
explain to you that the case for why why
here in America it is it does lead to
voter voter suppression to ask for IDs
where we've done a long form deep dive
on this so we did there's a lot tied
into this but this is part of the
package of voter suppression that the
right has very to differing degrees of
success perpetuated in the United States
and we've dealt very very specifically
in detail with it so I'm not going to go
through the full scope of it now but
you're right within a European
perspective how is it that just
requiring an ID can be a form of voter
disenfranchisement but unfortunately it
is here in the United
States and we've got a bunch of videos
on the YouTube channel about it really
appreciate your call that does it for
today thanks to everybody who called and
apologies to everybody I did not get to